all right welcome back everybody okay so
this is the end of the third week of
class and I believe we're on the seventh
lecture okay so I just posted homework
to yesterday around noon this one's a
little bit more involved in the first
homework it's due a week from today
and we're gonna start dealing with some
real physical systems okay so you're
gonna deal with the double spring-mass
system you're also going to deal with a
pendulum that's both in its stable
configuration and an inverted
configuration and I'm really want you to
start thinking about what eigenvectors
and eigenvalues physically mean for real
systems in terms of the solutions of F
equals MA okay so just a quick overview
of what we're gonna do today I'm gonna
tell you more about eigenvalues and
eigenvectors in the context of
diagonalizing Oh des we're gonna look at
the geometry of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors some methods for how to
solve for them in general with some
examples and then we're going to get
back to solutions of the matrix system
of equations x dot equals ax thinking
about phase portraits and what solutions
to this OD e look like for different
initial conditions and then next week
what we're going to do is we're gonna
start looking at so we've been looking
at these linear dynamical systems
dynamical just means they change in time
and soon we're gonna start looking at
nonlinear systems where x equals a
non-linear function of x okay so for
example a double pendulum or a satellite
in the planetary gravitational field or
a real elastic beam that's deflected a
lot all of these things are nonlinear
okay and what we're going to figure out
is how to determine when we can
represent those nonlinear systems with
this linear equation when this linear
equation is valid and how to analyze
solutions okay so we're gonna go from
linear systems to nonlinear systems
which opens up lots and lots of
interesting physical systems and then
after that we're going to move in
to the numerical analysis of these
systems because most real-world Odie's
can't actually be solved in closed form
you know these linear ones are some of
the only ones we can actually solve okay
any questions about where we're going or
what we've done so far or anything up to
this point nope okay good okay so today
we're going to talk mostly about
eigenvalues and eigenvectors okay so
remember you can all download these
notes they're always posted usually like
a day before but sometimes the very
morning of the lecture ok so I want you
to recall that to diagonalize the OD e X
dot equals a times X remember X as a
vector a is a matrix we need a
coordinate transformation and that
coordinate transform looks like X is
some matrix times a new variable Z okay
so there's some linear mapping from Z to
X and vice-versa via T inverse so that
if I wrote my dynamics in the vector in
the variable Z I would have Z dot equals
some diagonal matrix times Z and this is
much much easier to solve right we know
how to solve diagonal nobody's really
simple okay and so the T that we're
looking for satisfies a times T equals T
times some diagonal matrix ok and
remember that this is my eigenvalue
equation so the columns of t are
eigenvectors and the diagonal entries of
d are eigenvalues ok this is just review
from last time so this is a kind of
matrix form of the eigen value eigen
vector problem columns of T are
eigenvectors d is a diagonal matrix and
the diagonal elements are eigenvalues of
a so these are eve x eigenvectors of a
and eigenvalues of a and so we're going
to really get into the heart of what
eigenvalues and eigenvectors mean and
how to solve for them today ok so I told
you before that eigen means
characteristic or latent and the best
way I've heard this German word
described so I don't speak German but
the best way I've heard this described
is if you boiled a pot of the a matrix
and you boiled all the water off
everything that is left all the residual
stuff is the eigen decomposition of a ok
it's the characteristic or latent
remainder after you've kind of done this
nice factorization of the a matrix ok
and this matrix form is a little bit
difficult to work with so what we're
going to do is use the classical form of
the eigenvalue and eigenvector that most
of us are familiar with which is i have
a times some vector sometimes I'll call
it C sometimes I'll call it X doesn't
matter just a variable equals lambda
times that vector C ok this is the form
we're not we're used to thinking of so C
is just a single column vector lambda is
just a number okay and so this equation
is the eigenvalue equation and it's only
true for very special vectors C and for
special values lambda ok so if you just
pick some random C vector and some
random lambda out of a hat this is
almost certainly not going to be true
it's only true for very very special
vectors C and very special values lambda
up the eigen vectors and eigen values ok
so let's just do a quick example and
figure out kind of what the geometry of
this situation looks like
okay so I like to think geometrically
ordinary differential equations physical
systems are physical they live in space
they have coordinates and so they're
fundamentally geometric so the example
I'm going to do okay just a quick poll
of the class how many of you remember
eigenvalues and eigenvectors well enough
to actually compute them how many of you
probably wouldn't know all of the
details if you tried to compute them by
hands it's totally fine
took me a little while to remember okay
so the way I like to think about this
what we're trying to do is we're trying
to find vectors a x equals lambda X okay
we trying to find special vectors so
that when I multiply them by a I just
scale them by some factor lambda they
get longer or shorter or maybe they
change direction they go in the opposite
direction so first let's just start
trying some vectors let's see what
happens when I multiply this matrix by
some vectors okay so I want to convince
you that generically this eigenvalue
equation is not going to be true except
for very very special vectors okay okay
so let's just try x equals 1 0 so this
is the X vector ok so I'm going to try a
little unit vector in the X Direction
I'm going to multiply it by a ok so what
is a times X 3 and minus 1 right I take
this vector column vector and I rotate
it and I multiply it by the first row
vector add up those numbers multiply it
by the second row vector add up those
numbers I get 3 and minus 1 so if I draw
that I got 1 2 3 minus 1 okay so this
new vector a times X is definitely not
just lambda times X it's in a totally
different direction there's no lambda
that I can multiply X by to make it look
like a X not an eigenvector okay so now
let's try x equals the Y vector 0 1 ok
so what is a X equal minus 1 and 3 okay
so now I'm going to try this little test
Y vector and I get minus 1 1 2 3
that's a times y ok also definitely not
in the Y direction
there's no lambda times a unit vector
and Y that will give me this new a times
y vector a times X vector so neither of
these are eigenvectors that's not not
good okay neither of those are
eigenvectors now this is kind of an easy
equation because it's symmetric and so I
might think that if I try something
symmetric like x equals 1 1 what is any
times X equal ok 3 minus 1 is 2 and
minus 1 plus 3 is also 2 so this is good
ok now this vector actually is in the
same direction okay so my little test
vector here X was in the 1 1 direction
and a times X is in the 2 2 direction so
so a times X is exactly in the same
direction as X and it's exactly two
times longer okay so this is an
eigenvector with lambda equals 2 as the
eigen value so it makes sense all right
if I take this X so a times X equals
exactly 2 times X so lambda equals 2 and
let's try the next one
so I'm just guessing here I haven't
showed you how to actually compute these
things I could try 1 minus 1 and now
what is a times X equal 4 so 3 minus
minus 1 is 4 and then minus 4 ok so if I
start in the 1 minus one direction then
a times that vector is in the one two
three four minus four direction okay so
a times X is in the same direction as X
and it's exactly four times my input X
okay so this is also an eigenvector with
lambda equals four
this makes sense okay this should be
pretty pretty straightforward but what I
really want to convince you of is that
these eigenvalues and eigenvectors have
a geometric meaning okay they take my
original coordinate system x1 and x2 and
they give me a new coordinate system red
direction and blue direction so that in
those directions if I multiply by a I
stay in that direction okay it's really
important for differential equations
because if I have some dynamics which is
stable in the red direction and unstable
in the blue direction if I start in the
red direction I'll always come in and if
I start in the blue direction I'll
always go out okay so this new
coordinate system is really really
useful for differential equations also
yeah
okay so what I think about it is the
eigenvectors are vectors that when you
multiply them by a they stay in the same
direction so I take my coordinate system
and I find the directions where if I
multiplied those directions by a the
answer would be in that same direction
okay and then lambda is how much a
scales each of those unit vectors and
that's a really good question so there's
there's another point here which is so
this is an eigenvector right 1 1 but x
equals to 2 is also an eigenvector right
if I take a times 2 2 I get 6 minus 2 is
4 and minus 2 plus 6 is also 4 and this
is lambda times X right it's 2 times X
so anything in this direction is
technically an eigenvector okay usually
you just pick a convention that you pick
like a unit normed I can vector so I
would probably say that the real eigen
vector c1 is equal to 1 over square root
of 2 in the 1 1 Direction okay so this
has unit lengths and it's in the correct
read direction so if you type I into
MATLAB it's going to give you a I in
vector that has unit norm or unit length
so that's how it picks from all of the
infinitely many I get vectors that's how
it picks which one to give you and it
has some convention to give you kind of
the positive one instead of the negative
one also but it doesn't always do that
so okay good all right so that's Augen
values and eigen vectors now I'm going
to show you how to do it in the most
general case for n by n systems
okay so in general we have an eigenvalue
equation we're trying to solve so we
have a times x equals lambda times X and
we want to solve for lambda and X we
know what a is okay good so I can always
write a number times a vector as that
number times the identity matrix times
that vector right identity times X is
always X so this is the same thing and
what this allows me to do is now a and
lambda identity are both matrices
they're both N by n matrices so I can
say a minus lambda n times x equals a
zero vector okay this isn't that's not
good
claim the identity so this is an N by n
matrix if I multiply it by a column
vector I get another n dimensional
column vector and that has to equal the
zero vector okay every row of this
equation has to equal 0 good ok so this
is kind of the useful form of the
eigenvalue equation for actually doing
math so what we have is the first case
would be like when would this equation
be satisfied what's the simplest way to
satisfy this equation
so if X is equal to zero that would be
super simple right x equals zero is
definitely a solution to this for every
single a you can possibly name okay but
this is boring this is not going to help
us okay
so case two is what I heard a lot of you
sang case two this could possibly be
equal to 0 if a minus lambda I is
singular okay what does it mean for a
minus lambda I to be singular the
determinant 0 so the determinant of a
minus lambda I is equal to 0
which means that this is singular now
I'm not going to kind of rehash all of
linear algebra because it would take too
much time and I'm assuming most of you
have seen most of it before but I want
you to have some idea of what this
condition means for determinant of a
minus lambda I to be equal to 0 ok so
what does it mean physically what is the
meaning of this determinant equaling 0
okay you can't invert the matrix that's
one visit that's one one meaning what's
another meaning it means that some of
the columns of this matrix are linearly
dependent on other columns meaning
they're kind of parallel with other
combinations of vectors what is that
what's another ramification what's the
geometric interpretation of this
determinant equaling 0
so I want us all to think geometrically
because I forget all the algebra I've
ever learned that was terrible at
algebra but geometry like we were born
understanding shapes or at least we
learned them very very quickly okay so
the determinant is this amazing single
quantity that tells you okay so if I
have a coordinate system x1 and x2 and
let's say I take my unit vector in x1
and x2 that defines a box with what area
1 ok now if I map each of these vectors
through my a matrix they might do
something like this ok and this red
parallelogram has a new area and the
area of this red parallelogram is equal
to the determinant of that matrix
whatever it is whatever matrix I used to
map these unit vectors into the red unit
but the red vectors that's what my
determinant is it's the new area of this
red volume now you you have to take this
for granted I'm not verifying this fact
I'm just telling you this is a principle
of what the determinant means in in n
dimensions I have n unit vectors and
they define a cube and what's the volume
of that cube 1 and if I take each of
those unit vectors and I map them
through some matrix B that defines a new
kind of parallel crystal looking
parallelepiped and the volume of that is
exactly given by the determinant of that
matrix B that I map those unit vectors
through so how could I possibly have
this determinant equals 0 how could this
red area actually be a 0 well so my unit
vectors can never be 0 I always have
unit vectors in RN and they're never 0
how could I possibly have a B matrix
such that this red parallelogram has
zero
area exactly if they map to the same
vector and they collapse into a zero
width parallelogram okay so what
determinant 0 means what determinant of
B equals zero means is that I map both
of those X vectors to the same direction
and so I have an empty parallelogram
okay that's the geometric interpretation
of what the determinant equaling zero
means and the ramification is extremely
powerful it means that I have a two
dimensional space and I'm collapsing it
onto one dimension I've lost an entire
dimension in this matrix B I've lost a
degree of freedom okay so I go from some
high dimensional space RN to some lower
dimensional space RM if my determinant
is equal to zero and what that did what
that means is that there's some
direction like there's some direction
that gets mapped to zero there's some
vector X such that when I multiply it by
this matrix it will go to zero because
some directions have to get mapped to
zero if I have a determinant equal to
zero so you can draw this picture you
can convince yourself that this is true
if I have a matrix B such that it has
zero area you know determinant of B
equals zero then there are some
directions that will get mapped to zero
they'll get collapsed out when I
multiply them by B so that's what that
means here is that the only way for this
equation to be true for a non zero X is
if this matrix is singular meaning it
collapses the directions to zero okay
that's case two and this is called the
characteristic equation alright this is
the good-old characteristic equation
this is a polynomial in lambda and the
roots of that polynomial are the
eigenvalues of a so we all know how to
take the determinant of a two by two
matrix
it was in the last lecture notes we
should all know how to take the
determinant of a three by three matrix
within these lecture notes and so when
you take that determinant you get a
third order polynomial in lambda and you
can factor it or you can plug it into
MATLAB and you can get the three roots
those are your three eigenvalues of a
and those are the only three lambdas
that could possibly make this matrix
singular so for those very very special
lambda values that satisfy this
polynomial equation I lose directions
and those directions that I lose are my
eigenvectors X okay you're going to need
to go through this on your own with a 2
by 2 and a 3 by 3 matrix and convince
yourself that this is true you're gonna
have to try this out you're gonna have
to test that this times your eigenvector
really does equal 0 and you know plot
how the unit vectors go should convince
yourself that this thing has zero area
this parallelogram okay ok so let's just
revisit our first example originally we
just solved this kind of by intuition we
guessed until we found eigenvalues so
now we're gonna solve it the principled
way using what we just arrived
okay so first of all what's a minus
lambda I equals a matrix what does that
matrix 3 minus lambda minus 1 minus 1
10s up that right good ok what's the
determinant of this matrix we minus
lambda squared minus plus 1 minus 1 okay
so this equals 3 minus lambda squared
minus 1 I'm just gonna factor this out
that's something like lambda squared
minus 6 lambda plus 9 minus 1 is plus 8
good so far and this has to equal 0
we're looking for eigen values eigen
values are the special lambdas that make
this characteristic polynomial equals 0
the roots of this polynomial okay so we
can factor this thing we get lambda
minus 2 that right lambda minus 2 times
lambda minus 4 starting to look unstable
equals 0 and so my eigenvalues are i
have two eigenvalues it's a second-order
polynomial so I have lambda 1 equals 2
and lambda 2 equals 4 good that's step
one step one is finding your eigenvalues
finding the special values that make
that a minus lambda I singular because
the only way I'm ever gonna find an
eigenvector is for lambda that make this
singular okay questions about this first
step
nope okay the first time I heard that
this determinant actually had a physical
meaning totally blew my mind it's
changed my life ever since I firstly not
kidding okay so step two is so now step
one was find lambda right set two is
find my eigenvector find X given lambda
okay so now we have lambdas that make my
system singular and I need to find which
vectors X map to 0 okay so we start with
lambda 1 equals 2 ok so we have a minus
2 times the identity a minus lambda I
equals what 1 minus 1 minus 1 1 okay a
minus to let 2 identity and this matrix
times some X vector some special eigen
vector has to equal 0
okay x1 x2 okay so a minus lambda I
times X has to equal zero
that's my eigenvector equation so what
do we know about X 1 and X 2 from this
equation there you have to be equal
right if I plug in x1 equals x2 then I
get x1 minus x1
definitely equals 0 and minus x1 plus x1
also equals 0 ok so this is satisfied
that this is true if x1 equals x2 and so
what that means is that my I'm gonna
call it C just so that it stands out
this is my special vector my eigen
vector c1 corresponding to lambda 1 is
equal to 1 1 right X 1 has to equal X 2
and anything that satisfies x1 equals x2
will be an eigen vector for lambda
equals 2 I mean I did this by hand you
could also do like factorization and try
to figure this out that way okay good so
let's try lambda 2 equals 4 same deal
okay a minus 4 lambda sorry a minus
lambda identity is equal to minus 1
minus 1 minus 1 minus 1
so we have minus 1 minus 1 minus 1 minus
1 times X 1 X 2 equals 0 0 ok so how can
this possibly be true for both rows
equal and opposite ok so if and only if
X 1 equals minus X 2 which means that my
second special vector C 2 is in the 1-1
direction right X 1 and X 2 are in the
opposite opposite signs okay so we just
solved this eigenvalue problem by hand
okay we started with we started with a x
equals sorry aches e equals lambda x e
we multiplied this by the identity and
subtracted to get a minus lambda I C
equals 0 and then we solve for lambdas
where this could possibly be true for
nonzero C and then we solve for the C
given those lambdas ok that's it you can
do this for an N by n system it's hard
it's very very very expensive but you
could do this for any system I give you
now ok
ok any questions about eigenvalues and
eigenvectors at all I want this to be
like multiplication used to be this
should be something that you feel deep
down inside these eigenvalues and
eigenvectors for a matrix a are a new
coordinate system where if I multiplied
a in those coordinate directions it
would just scale those directions ok
so you could try this for the system in
fact this is a homework problem a lot of
the homework problems are based around
this but we had a differential equation
X double dot plus 3 X dot plus 2x equals
0 and I could write this as X dot equals
V V dot equals -2 X minus 3 V which is a
system of equations DDT of X V equals a
matrix 0 1 minus 2 minus 3x V this is a
as practice for the homework you should
compute the eigenvalues and eigenvectors
of this matrix by hand and then use that
to solve this differential equation in
this form ok basically what we just did
here I tried doing this on my plane ride
home from California and I had had a
half a bottle of wine and I could not do
it so I recommend being sober the one I
chose here 3 minus 1 minus 1 3 is a
little bit easier but not a lot ok ok so
we want to tie this back to differential
equations right we're trying to solve
systems that you know have motion F
equals MA and we started to get an idea
of how we could use eigenvalues and
eigenvectors in the last lecture to
solve real systems that change in time
ok so let's see how I want to do this ok
in MATLAB what is the command to compute
the eigenvalues and eigenvectors of a
matrix a i''k okay so I would say T D
equals AG of a and I'd probably put a
semicolon so it doesn't fill my screen
with garbage ok and what is the
fundamental relationship between T D and
a right so a T equals T D it does not
equal DT you should try it like you
can't flip these two because they're
matrices won't work my PhD advisor
pointed that out to me multiple times so
we can then say that a equals T times D
times T inverse right to get rid of this
guy I'm going to take the inverse on the
right and I'm gonna write multiply with
T inverse this doesn't always work
there's not I'm glossing over some
details in linear algebra I'm kind of
assuming that I have you know either
real eigenvalues or an orthogonal set of
eigenvectors T it's a little more
complicated and we'll get into that kind
of in the next week or two we'll talk
about when I cannot write a like this
but for now let's just assume that I
have nice distinct eigenvalues that are
all different for a real valued matrix a
and then I'm guaranteed to have an
orthogonal set of eigenvectors for key
so I can invert it all right if I have
an orthogonal set of columns meaning
none of them are linearly dependent its
determinant is nonzero and I can invert
it okay that was like all of linear
algebra just now ok so any equals T
times D times T inverse
and so we know that a squared equals T
times d squared times P inverse right
like just try it things cancel a cubed
equals T D cubed T inverse and so on
forever
okay this is a really really really nice
simple formula this is fundamentally
related to the fact that we pointed out
earlier that if I write a in a new
coordinate system T then if I multiply a
a bunch of times those column vectors of
T stay in the same direction and they
just get scaled by their eigen value to
a power you know two then three then
four okay so we know that our solution X
dot equals ax right we know that this
should have a solution X at times T
equals a matrix e to the a T times the
vector X at time not okay this has to be
you can't flip the order of these
because this is a matrix and this is a
column vector so you have to have X not
on the right and now we're equipped to
actually solve eetu the a T we can
actually write down e to the a T in a
convergent Taylor series using this very
very nice I in value decomposition okay
so e to the eighty equals last lecture I
totally forgot to include any time that
was a mistake
so this equals an identity plus 80 plus
one-half a squared T squared plus
one-third factorial a cube T cube plus
more stuff forever and ever and ever
okay any of the matrix a squared as a
matrix a cubed as a matrix identity as a
matrix this whole thing as a matrix
times a matrix of time okay
okay but now what we can do this is
really cool we can factor out a t on the
left and a t inverse on the right
because I don't want to be computing aid
in the fifth Sunday to the 10th try it
sometime for for a real a matrix it
sucks you can't do it and you'll never
get a nice expression okay so what I'm
gonna do is I'm going to say this is
really T times T inverse that's identity
right plus Big T times D times T inverse
time plus 1/2 T times d squared times T
inverse x squared plus 1 over 3
factorial t d cubed T inverse time cubed
plus so on and so forth so all of these
terms have a t on the left and a T
inverse on the right so I can say this
is T times identity plus DT plus 1 over
2 d squared t plus 1 over 3 factorial d
cubed T cubed plus dot dot T inverse
maybe a little less sloppy this is
really important no time to be careless
so d cubed T cubed plus dot dot dot all
of that is right multiplied by T
universe right every term here had a T
on the left and a T inverse on the right
so I just popped those on the left and
the right and I get T times this big
expression only in terms of diagonal
matrices identity as a diagonal matrix
times T inverse okay now this is kind of
cool
all of these diagonal matrices I know
exactly what they do when I take them to
a high dimension to a high power like
what's D to the 10th power
not as hard as it sounds so D equals
lambda 1 lambda 2 dots bunch of zeros
what happens if I take D to the tenth
power lambda 1 to the tenth lambda 2 to
the 10th and then a bunch of zeros
lambda 1 to the 10th lambda 2 to the
10th dot dot dot but not 0 when I'm two
ends of the 10th so all of these terms
are super super simple and I can
actually write this sum for every
location in this matrix okay it lambda 1
plus lambda 2 squared over 2 T squared
plus lambda 1 cubed T cubed over 3
factorial and what I get is I'll just
write it out long ways
okay so what I get is T times now this
thing looks like e to the D T okay and
that's e to the lambda 1t e to the
lambda 2 T dot e to the lambda n T so
this is kind of the magic step that I
almost skipped so you can convince
yourself that if you write out identity
plus DT plus d squared T plus D cube T
then you get a bunch of little Taylor
series that add up to e to the lambda 1t
either lambda 2 T and so on on the
diagonal everything off diagonal is 0
okay so this equals so this means e to
the a T equals my big matrix of
eigenvectors times e to the diagonal T
times T inverse okay so this is awesome
you're gonna box this this gets red with
blue stars okay this is one of the main
results in the class okay this is kind
of this is where linear algebra and
differential equations meet and you can
solve almost any system in an incredibly
simple way each of the diagonal T is as
simple as if all of my dynamics were
decoupled and the way that I can write
my solution in that simplified way is by
using eigen vector changes of
coordinates where T rygan vectors of a
okay questions
I'm gonna hammer this home one more time
it's really important so next time on
Monday we're going to start using this
expression of eigenvalues and
eigenvectors to start solving two-by-two
systems and analyzing their stability
their longtime behavior their phase
portraits these are extremely useful
engineering tools for like very rapidly
sketching what the behavior of a system
will look like for long times you can
use this for feedback control if you
want to stabilize a system you can use
it for design if you want some time
characteristics of your system this is
going to be incredibly useful okay so we
had right so we have eigenvectors and
eigenvalues you can absolutely use this
for complicated signals that you want to
decompose so the idea of using a change
of coordinates so x equals some change
of coordinates z it's useful in
differential equations right if T are
the eigenvectors of a then that's a very
useful change of coordinates for
differential equations if I have some
measurement signal like like if I take
my iPhone and I put it on my car and I
measure the vibrations of my car let's
say I want to know what the different
frequency components that it's picking
up are then I would use T which is a
discrete Fourier transform okay so if I
want to take the Fourier transform of
something there is a matrix T that will
do it for you the Fourier transform is a
change of coordinates from my
measurement data to frequency domain
okay there are tons of these wavelets is
a matrix transformation Fourier
transform matrix transformation
eigenvectors gives me a very special
matrix transform for Oh DES so thinking
about the geometry that's why I'm
harping on the geometry of things
because I want us to be thinking about
coordinate transformations into useful
coordinate systems where things become
in the case of OD EES simple means
diagonal diagonal eyes that dynamics
okay great question okay good
so T is a big matrix of eigenvectors c1
c2 Delta C n D is a big diagonal matrix
of eigenvalues lambda 1 lambda 2 lambda
n zeros everywhere else okay and we had
X dot equals a times X and we know that
the solution X of T equals wait I think
we just did it so it's T e to the DT T
inverse times X naught okay so what I'm
trying to show here okay this is just
what we've done for the last two
lectures I have some system X dot equals
ax and I can write the solution X of T
in terms of this but what we're really
doing is the following so I take my
initial condition X naught and I
multiply it by T inverse what's T
inverse X naught
z not right I'm so Z equals T inverse X
so if I take T inverse X naught this is
Z naught this is my initial condition in
my eigenvector coordinate system if what
my initial condition is if I wrote it in
terms of a sum of eigenvectors okay we
know that in this coordinate system Z
dot equals D times Z super easy to solve
what's the solution of that Z of T
equals e to the diagonal matrix super
simple times Z naught okay so we know
how to solve this differential equation
in the eigenvector coordinate system but
I want this in physical units I want it
in meters and XY and Z so what do I do
finally I have my solution in Z and
eigenvector coordinates now I map it
back to X by multiplying with T so T
times Z T equals X at my at that point
of time so that is physically what we're
doing that's what this actually means
okay that's this is a fancy expression
we just derived in fact we derived the
condition for eigenvalues and eigen
vectors to find the T and a D that
allows us to do this so eigen vectors
and eigen values are not mystical they
are specifically designed to do this
they give me a coordinate system where
in that coordinate system my solution is
simple and then I can easily map back to
my original measurement system okay
that's all I've got
we have five minutes if there's any
questions this has been a little bit
theoretical next week we're going to do
examples and real a matrices that's all
have a great weekend